good morning believe nation its Evan my
one word is believe in I believe in
people more than they believe in
themselves and my sincere hope is that
if you see in yourself what I see in you
you'll be able to change the planet so
help you on your journey today's message
is become irreplaceable over to you
Priyanka Chopra when I was very young I
was 19 and I was doing first few movies
I remember that the producer just said
well she can't work it out it's fine
we'll just cause someone else girls are
replaceable subconsciously it really
worked on my mind and I started picking
up parts which were strong which were
not just the damsel in distress waiting
for someone to rescue me now
13 15 years later the movies that I do
I'm a replaceable if you want to be a
success in whatever you're doing then
you have to be so good at it that you're
irreplaceable if I can swap out your
product or your service with somebody
else's really easily then you're never
gonna stand out you're never gonna
really build a successful business it's
going to be a race down to the bottom
for price if I can't tell the difference
between what you're selling and what
your competitors are selling then I'm
just gonna go with whoever's is the
cheapest and that's where a lot of
entrepreneurs are playing now price is
always going to be important but it's
not always the most important thing for
a majority of a lot of customers you
just haven't done your job to stand out
enough I think it's also really
important to balance your ego with your
humbleness I think it's important to
have both I think a lot of entrepreneurs
and a lot of people play on one side of
the spectrum and not enough of the other
and so a lot of entrepreneurs we don't
have enough ego we don't have enough
pride we don't have enough confidence in
ourselves to go out and charge what
we're worth to feel like we're worthy I
think a lot of entrepreneurs could boost
their prices 20 25 30 % and not see a
dip in their customers I think too many
entrepreneurs just underpriced
themselves because they don't have
enough confidence in what they're
selling what they're doing
I think too though you balance it with
humbleness because if you are not humble
then you'll never grow and you'll never
learn and you never try to get better
you never try to keep improving because
you think you know everything and so if
I look at my youtube channel as an
example I've had a number of
conversation with different people
talking about my channel and often it'll
start with me saying all the things that
I want to work on right like I need to
get better I need to create better
content I need to make three solid
videos a day that people love and every
series is leading to growth to the
channel and it's having a big impact on
the audience reached and a lot of times
and that's reaction people will be try
to be supportive and say well you're
making three videos a day like I I'm I'm
making one a week or I struggled to make
one a week like you're you're already
you're already doing great you're
already having such a big impact you
shouldn't be so hard on yourself and
this is where the danger comes in
because if I just live to their
expectations and I'm just some big fish
in this tiny pond it's easy to feel good
about myself right it's easy to say well
you know you're right if I compare
myself to all these other YouTube
channels where they're making one video
in a week and that's really hard and
that's really good for them then I lower
my standards to where they're at and
what they see is excellent where for me
I have greater standards for myself and
so I push myself to want to do more
I believe the editing can be better I
believe the filming can be better I
believe I give you better I believe the
content we had to me better everything
can always be better and I'll push
yourself to go out and do it and at the
same time I think my channel is the
greatest YouTube channel period I think
my channel is a gift to humanity I think
if a YouTube channel was gonna win a
Nobel Prize it should be my channel I
love my channel I consumed my own
channel more than any other channel and
I think it's it's a gift to humanity I
do I believe that and it needs to get a
lot better
right so embracing both sides and so I
think feeling that same way about your
business feeling like the work that
you're doing can always get better can
always improve you can improve your
skills and your hustle and your drive
and how much practice you put in an
energy and there's always something new
to learn you're never done learning
so as you stop learning you're done and
you're also providing a lot of value
you have a great product or great
service there's a lot of love that goes
in there's a noticeable difference
between you and somebody else the rest
of your competition feeling that because
if you don't feel that your customers
won't feel that either if somebody gets
on the call with you or meets with you
and you can't with pride explain why
you're different and why you're better
and for them to see that result they
can't see it they're not gonna pay you
more they're not gonna pick you over
somebody else and that means ultimately
that you can't grow your business as big
as it should be it's the balance
humbleness plus ego / confidence become
irreplaceable so the question today
today is I'm curious what is the thing
that makes you irreplaceable what's so
special unique different about your
business that nobody else can do just
like you leave it down the comments
below I'm really curious to find out and
also if you leave a comment within the
first couple hours of this video going
live you have a chance of winning one of
our two daily prizes I also want to give
a quick try to two dev God V dev thank
you so much you're picking up a copy of
my book and doing the review on your
channel for your audience kara nation
for doing the interview with Lily and
all the love and support you've given
for my book your one word I really
appreciate it ma'am and I'm so glad that
you enjoyed the read thank you guys
again for watching I believe in you I
hope you continue to believe in yourself
and whatever your one word is much love
and I'll see you again tomorrow morning
for another shot of an espresso
you know in your life you will start a
job and this what I say to every single
new person coming into Pixar no matter
what you do make yourself indispensable
to that organization make yourself
indispensable we're people after you're
done with your job people cannot imagine
the place without you and without asking
for a thing your career will be set you
can be a history maker or you can be
liked by everyone around you you can't
be both
I mean the very nature of living your
personal greatness and doing something
otherworldly in our world of ours means
you're gonna have to think differently
from the majority you're gonna have to
install the habits and routines that
most people don't do you're going to
have to live talk breathe walk work
produce create in a way that most people
who are card-carrying members of the
cult of mediocrity just don't buy into
when you look at most people out on the
world today and this is not judging this
is just reporting but they're addicted
to entertainment they love gossiping
they're negative they're toxic anyone
who wants to do anything great they want
to bring them down they dismiss the game
changers and they're just coasting
through life and so the very nature of
you stepping up your game living your
greatest potential owning your craft
dominating your field and living a life
that's legendary means you're gonna have
to leave the 5% and make a decision to
live as very few people do and what does
that mean it means you're going to be
laughed at it means you're gonna be
ridiculed it means you're going to be
misunderstood because leadership is a
lonely sport and it means you just might
be hated
we talked about coolers we talked about
closers and that we talked about
cleaners cleaners going to get you that
end result over and over again they are
so well prepared and their instincts are
so sharp they already know what to do if
there's a person that's producing
exceptionally there's a reason behind it
it's the process the constant challenge
to get there again and again and again
is what drives these individuals
everyone talks about we want to be
legendary you want to be iconic
don't settle for legendary